so I'm not really sure what Sony is up
to they themselves are releasing
spoilers for their upcoming movies like
morbius but we're not complaining
because we're actually getting some
Spider-Man news out of this what's going
on everybody welcome back to the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things Marvel
and MCU I'm your host Warren Thompson
and Sony recently on Twitter the
director of morbius did an ask me
anything where he revealed some spoilers
for the movie and Sony retweeted it
therefore they revealed some spoilers
about the movie but again we're not
complaining because they did reveal that
a new Spider-Man announcement will be
coming soon they said Spider-Man does
exist in their Sony universe and they're
going to show us who he is soon who
could this be well we'll break it down
in this video and of course if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos so
we're going to go over this entire
Twitter thread but don't worry we're not
going to talk about spoilers until the
latter half of the video because we have
to talk about the morbius post credit
scene which they actually spoiled in
this thread which is just kind of crazy
to me but director of morbius Daniel
Espinoza has answered some Spider-Man
questions so we're going to break those
down and then talk about the post credit
which does have to do with Spider-Man
but kind of doesn't make sense at the
same time but first things first we talk
about Spider-Man on the Cinema Blend
official Twitter account they posted
attention Spider-Man fans we have a
special Friday treat morbius movie
director Daniel Espinoza agreed to
answer every juicy questions you have
about Spider-Man Venom vulture and all
the Marvel Easter eggs in the upcoming
movie are you ready and they literally
say spoilers in the thread and I just
want to point out that the picture that
they used for this is morbius with
Spider-Man in the background and we're
gonna come back to this later because
it's very important now the thread
starts out with some relatively simple
questions that offer a bit of clarity
about the movie and kind of the universe
as a whole in fact the first question is
what Universe does morbius take place in
in which the director answered morbius
lives in the same universe as Venom this
is the universe we saw Venom exit at the
end of Venom Let There Be Carnage and
return to at the end of Spider-Man no
way home and side note slash rant they
really got us with that post-credit
scene for Venom Let There Be Carnage
they really made us think that Tom
Hardy's Eddie Brock and Venom we're
going to go up against Tom Holland's
Peter Parker Spider-Man but then they
just brought him back at the end of
Spider-Man no way home they really
played with us there but morbius and
Venom are in the same universe which we
already knew they literally say Venom in
the morbius trailer but here's where
things get good the next question that
was asked was is there a Spider-Man in
Venom's Universe in which Daniel
Espinoza said of course in which the
question came after was okay so which
Spider-Man exists in Venom's universe
and with that question they put a gif of
all three Spider-Man from the way home
Andrew Garfield Spider-Man Toby
McGuire's and of course Tom Hollands in
which Daniel Espinosa replied it is my
understanding that audiences will
discover the answer soon so we are going
to be getting a new Spider-Man
announcement relatively soon according
to the director of morbius now I say new
Spider-Man because this is not going to
be Tom Holland's Spider-Man Tom Holland
Spider-Man is not going to exist both in
the MCU and in the Sony picture Universe
of Marvel characters whatever the heck
they're calling it he's not going to
exist in both and the post-credits scene
for Spider-Man Noe home made that very
clear they took the Venom symbiote and
basically took a part of it and put it
in the MCU making it very clear this is
not going to be Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock
it's going to be a new Venom going up
against Tom Holland Spider-Man making
the division between the universes very
clear plus not to mention Eddie Brock
did not know who Spider-Man was so it's
not Tom Holland Spider-Man in this Sony
universe so we're getting a new
Spider-Man that isn't Tom Holland and of
course the big question is who could it
be well first off here's something very
interesting I said we'd come back to
that picture of morbius with Spider-Man
in the background apparently this is no
longer in the movie now why is this not
in the movie why is that picture of
Spider-Man not in the background anymore
we're not really sure however one thing
you should keep in mind is that morbius
finished filming like three years ago a
lot has happened since then in the Sony
Spider-Man universe and in the MCU no
way home came out it was a massive
success bringing the other two
Spider-Man back that can change things
and I think that is what happened the
success of Spider-Man no way home has
changed Sony's plans for Spider-Man in
their universe so whatever plan they had
before putting Spider-Man on the wall in
this morbius scene has clearly changed
because they have taken that out but
they do have plans for Spider-Man which
we'll talk about in just a bit but again
who could the Spider-Man be could it
actually be Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
returning I personally think so I think
Andrew got a lot of redemption in
Spider-Man no way home I think fans were
more than excited to see him back and
now we have a make tasm 3 petition and
if I were Sony I would not ignore that
especially if I needed a Spider-Man for
my universe and also keep in mind Andrew
Garfield's Spider-Man said that he never
went against an alien he said I want to
fight an alien so he's never seen Venom
before so bringing him back would be a
perfect opportunity for him to finally
go against Venom because although I
would love if Toby Maguire returned to
play Spider-Man one I do think he is
kind of too old now unfortunately not
too old to make some cameos but too old
to go through multiple Spider-Man movies
again Andrew of course is older now but
still could play the role and since
Tobey Maguire Spider-Man already went up
against a Venom you can't really say
that he exists in this universe with Tom
Hardy's Venom because they've never met
that was made clear by the Spider-Man
Noe home post credit scene Eddie Brock
did not know who Spider-Man was I'm sure
they could retcon it somehow but what
would make the most sense is to use
indigo Spider-Man this way the Venom
Spider-Man story could be from scratch
in the Sony Universe now of course there
is the option that they could simply
introduce a new Spider-Man however I
think this would be a pretty bad idea I
think Andrew is definitely the best bet
but let me know what you think now right
now we're going to be talking about
spoilers for the morbius post credit
scenes so if you don't want to be
spoiled you should click away now
although they do have to do with
Spider-Man so again this was literally
revealed on Twitter by the director and
Sony retweeted it but Cinema Blinn asks
let's shift to Michael Keaton who we saw
in your morbius trailers is he playing
the same Adrian tomb vulture from
Spider-Man Homecoming in which the
answer was yes and the follow-up
question was how did he get to Venom and
morbius's universe here's the answer at
the end of Venom Let There Be Carnage
and Spider-Man no way home and in no way
home itself it is clearly established
that it is possible for characters to
transfer from one Multiverse to another
the events of no way home had the effect
of transferring Venom and vulture and
maybe others back and forth between the
MCU and the the Venom Universe this
doesn't really make sense because Adrian
tombs originally started off in the MCU
Venom originally started off in the Sony
Universe when the spell happened Venom
got transferred over to the MCU when the
spell got undone he got sent back well
Adrian was already in the MCU so if he
did get sent out of the universe it
probably would have been to the Sony
universe but then he should have came
back when the spell was undone I
shouldn't say undone when Doctor Strange
did the new spell but again vulture
should have come back or he should have
never actually left the MCU in the first
place so this really doesn't make sense
but it has me concerned but moving on to
the post-credits scene which is a
vulture talking to morbius about getting
revenge on Spider-Man the last question
Cinema Blend asked was is vulture and
morbius setting up for a Sinister Six
movie in which Daniel Espinoza said well
he is recruiting teammates and he has
enticed one already so it sure looks
like a start so it looked looks like
there is going to be a true Sinister Six
Spider-Man movie with this new
Spider-Man that they should be
announcing soon Sony clearly has some
pretty big plans for Spider-Man they're
Spider-Man who I do believe is going to
be Andrew Garfield so let's hope that
his Redemption from Spider-Man no way
home doesn't get messed up and Sony
actually has a plan with everything that
they're doing right now morbius craving
the hunter Madame Webb let's hope they
get it right let me know your thoughts
about all of this in the comments down
below including who you think this new
Spider-Man of the Sony universe is going
to be drop your thoughts down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on all
things Marvel and MCU for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf